[موسيقى]
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم الحقيقه انا
حابب اطرح في هذه الحلقه على ضيفي الاستاذ
الدكتور علي الدين هلال المفكر السياسي
البرمو سؤال بيشغلني وبيشغل الكثيرين جدا
عن موقع الولايات المتحده في هذا العالم
وخصوصا في المنطقه العربيه اسمح لي اطرحه
على حضرتك بطريقه يعني ليست علميه جدا
يعني اتفضل هل انا اذكر انه الرئيس ريجن
كان اول رئيس امريكي يصف الاتحاد السوفيتي
بانه امبراطوريه الشر على مدار السنوات
الكثيره الماضيه من منتصف الثمانينات والى
الان الولايات المتحده خصوصا بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي تورطت في يعني جرائم
كثيره واغضب كثير من الشعوب وباتت فكره
المعايير المزدوجه والنفاق في الممارسات
الدوليه سمه مرتبطه بالولايات المتحده
السؤال باختصار هل بدت الولايات المتحده
مؤهله لنفس اللقب الذي اطلقه ريجن على
الاتحاد السوفيتي الولايات المتحده
امبراطوريه الشر في العالم الان شوف بص
يعني ممكن ناس كثيرين يوافقك على هذا
التصور انما يعني هو في النهايه تعبير
ايديولوجي اه
يعني وانا ما عنديش مشكله سواء وصفها او
وصف اي دوله تانيه ترتكب اعمال مماثله بس
انا بفضل يعني كاستاذ جامعي و
احلل يعني بدلا من اطلاق الاحكام
تحليل المواقف والاتجاهات
والتعرف على الدوافع لماذا تخدم امريكا
على هذا الامر او دي ممكن بقى في نهايه
التحليل نقول اه دي تمثل امبراطوريه الشر
او لا تمثله في كل الاحوال هي عندما تقدم
على سلوك ما باعثها الرئيسي هو
مصالحها ماذا يتحقق مصالحها مصالحها
الاقتصاديه مصالحها العسكريه مصالحها
الامنيه وفقا لتعريفها هي ووفقا لتعريف
نخبتها السياسيه الولايات المتحده مجتمع
جديد يعني هي ليست كغلي الدول الاوروبيه
او اغلب الدول
العربيه اللي فيها سكان عايشين على هذه
الارض من مئات السنين او الاف السنين الس
هي دوله تكونت عن طريق الهجره عمرها اقل
من 300 سنه يعني هي كندا استراليا
نيوزيلاند اسرائيل جنوب افريقيا في وقت
التمييز العنصري الاستيطان الفرنسي في
الجزائر دي مجتمعات مهاجره وانا اهتميت
يعني في تاريخي العلمي ان ابحث ايه خصائص
هذا النوع من
المجتمعات اللي ممكن تسميه اما مجتمعات
مهاجره او مجتمعات
استيطان يعني ناس بتنتقل من بلادها
الاصليه الى بلاد جديده وتستوطن هذه الارض
على حساب احيانا سكانها الاصليه طبعا هو
في كل الاحيان مافيش احيانا في كل الاحيان
اول سمه للمجتمعات دي يا استاذ سيد
استخدام العنف ان هو الطريقه التي يتعامل
معها مع السكان الاصليين هي
العنف في مثل شهير في امريكا يعني العنف
وزي فطيره التفاح اللي هي يعني حاجه من
يعني الحلويات الامريكيه الصرفه اه الابل
باي ففا لنس از از امريكان از ابل باي ابل
باي ا يعني ان هي ايه التاريخ اما اباده
السكان الاصليين اللي احنا بنسميه خطا
الهنود الحمر اه لكن دي قبائل لها لغتها و
دياناتها وتاريخها وثقافاتها يعني مجتمعات
تم اباده جزء من ه الناس او
قصفهم الى
معازل حتى الان اسموها
ريزيرف وحتى الان في امريكا مناطق ريزيرف
كذا مع ذلك للسكان الاصليين يعني في ده
جزء من تاريخ هذه
المجتمعات نفس الشيء في كندا وفي استراليا
كندا اعترفت
بيه مش بس اعترفت بيه لو تذكر
يعني اذكر حضرتك وال المشاهدين الكرام
حوالي سنتين بابا روما سافر الى الى الغرب
في كندا في
فانكوفر لكي يوجه اعتذارا
بنفسه
عن المجازر التي سكتت عنها الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه ضد السكان الاصليه في كندا في
كندا صحيح وهتلاقي كان بعضهم طالب كينج تش
دلوقتي اللي هو كان ولي العهد بانه يطلب
من العائله المالكه الاعتذار عن الجرائم
التي
ارتكبوها ضد السكان الاصليين باعتبار ان
ملكه بريطانيا هي ملكه كندا صح صح صح
وكندا مجملها كانت اقل عنفا من امريكا نفس
الشيء واقل قوه واقل قوه اقل قوه فاذا
حضرتك المجتمع الامريكي في ثقافته في
حضارته القوه سهله
عليه لذلك على ه على هذا الاساس تفهم ان
امريكا الدوله الوحيده حضرتك تروح محل
تشتري مدفع اسلحه اه او
بندقيه حضرتك لا يمر اسبوع في في امريكا
دون حدوث اعتداء بالعنف من جانب احد الناس
الى اذا فهو مجتمع عنيف بحكم تركيبته
القائمه على المهاجرين
وثقافته ثقافته اللي هي اللي هي كمهاجرين
استولوا على ارض غيرهم فكان لازم يستخدم
القوه الحاجه الثانيه التوسع يعني
مجتمع يقوم على فكره
التوسع
تاريخيا المستوطنين الاوائل جم على الساحل
الشرقي ل يقولوا نيويورك فيلادلفيا نيو
جيرسي سدوا يتجهوا غربا
غربا لا يعني التوسع العظيم بعد ما انشات
امريكا لاوا حت اسمها تكساس دي
تاريخيا جزء من
المكسيك وحتى الان اسامي
البلاد اللغه الثانيه
المستخدمه عدد كبير من الناس
مكسيك فتم من خلال حرب الاستلا على
المكسيك تكساس السمه التانيه قلتلك
التوسع مجتمع
يعني يسعى
لتوسيع
نفوسه احنا ساعات يعني في كتبنا او كلامنا
نقول ان امريكا اتبع اساس العزله لغايه
الحرب العالميه الاولى ده مش صحيح هي
العزله تجاه اوروبا انما هي يدها كانت
مطلقه في امريكا اللاتينيه ده صحيح دي ده
دي معلومه مهبه واستاذن حضرتك لاصدقائنا
او المتابعين يعني لمن لا يعلمون هذه
المعلومه انه التيار الاساسي اللي كان في
الولايات المتحده قبل الحرب العالميه
الاولى ان ان هم ينقوا بانفسهم عن القوى
الكبرى والقوى الاوروبيه في قاره اوروبا
فاحنا زي ما معالي الدكتور بيقول المستقر
في اذهاننا ان الامريكان كانوا عاوزين
يكونوا بعيدين عن مشاكل العالم ويبقى هم
بس مشاكلهم داخل الولايات المتحده دكتور
بيوضح لنا معلومه مهمه بيقول لا هم كانوا
بس عاوزين ينقوا بانفسهم عن مشاكل اوروبا
لكن هم كانوا عاوزين يسيطروا ويوسعون
نفوذهم في الامريك
حتى في الفتره دي هم بداوا يستكشفوا
العالم من خلال التبشير يعني كان بيسموها
الارساليه
الامريكيه انا بتكلم على منتصف القرن
التاس عر اللي منها راحت لايران ايران
والعراق
والكويت والبحرين والارساليه دي كانت
بتعتمد على دي كانت مجتمعات تعبانه قوي من
حيث الخدمات مستشفيات
مدارس مدارس يعني ما كانش التبشير بمعنى
ان عايز اقنعك ان دين وكذا من خال تقديم
خدمات تجعلك
اكثر احتراما وتقديرا
وتوقيرا
وقبولا لهذا الدين اللي بيعمل كذا وكذا
وده اللي جعل صوره امريكا في بعض البلدان
ومنها ايران اللي هي بالنسبه لها دلوقتي
عدو ندود يعني انها كانت صوره ايجابيه جدا
قبل طبعا الثوره الايرانيه يعني حبه مصدقه
في الكويت اخد الكويت اول مستشفى المستشفى
الامريكي سنه
1912 او
13 لم يكن هناك اي طب حديث حتى انشاء
المستشفى يعني عايز اقول هي برض امريكا من
منتصف القرن التاس ع بدات تتحسس العالم
باقل الطرق تكلفه اه البعثات الت بشيريه
وانشاء الجامعات
والمدارس انشاء الجامعات ا الجامعه
الامريكيه في بيروت وغيرها جماعه امريكيه
في القاهره اللي هي كان اسمها قبل كده
الكليه البروتستانتيه اه جت الحرب
العالميه
الاولى
ويلسون رئيس الرئيس الامريكي ويلسون
المصير اللي هو كان استاذ علوم سياسيه
والله طبعا استاذ علوم
سياسيه واصبح رئيس الج ووله كتب جه حضر
مؤتمر فيرساي وقال المبادئ ال 14
1920 كلام يعني ومنها حق تقرير المصير
للشعوب والحريات والكلام ده كله ووقتها
كان في وفد مصري وسعد باشا
زغلول لا والقضيه الفلسطينيه بقى والقضيه
اليهوديه وكل القضايا كل القضايا دي
المؤسسه الحاكمه في امريكا يعني حست انها
مش مستعده لسه انها تخش في هذا المعتر
معترك ايه بقى مع معترك الدولي بقى
بتكلفته ا فغير الكلام الحلو ده
مشيوا وانهزم بعد كده ويلسون في
الانتخابات
وخلاص البدايه بقى الحقيقيه زي ما حضرتك
قلت بعد الحرب الثانيه شوف بص ما كان يمكن
للانتصار الدول
الغربيه يعني لو كان الامر ترك لبريطانيا
وفرنسا كانوا هزموا اولا فرنسا كانت هزمت
هزمت بفعل
واحتلت وباريس احتلت وديجول ج عاش في
الجزائر وانشا حكومه فرنسا
الحره بريطانيا
جزيره فلولا امريكا ل هزمت قوى الحلفاء
امريكا والاتحاد السوفيتي اه
طبعا الاتحاد السوفيتي خسر 20 مليون
موت كان معركه ستالينجراد الى
اخره انما امريكا شعت بقى بقوتها
وان هي قائد القوات المتحالفه الغربيه
ايزنهاور وهم اللي عملوا الانزال انزال
هذه القوات في
نورمندي وقبلوا بلاء حسنا الانتصار بدات
شمس انجلترا فرنسا تقفل طبعا المانيا لا
اتهزمت خالص
ويصعد واصبحت امريكا طرفا فاعلا في هذه
العمليه وتالي بقى لعب دور رئيسي في انشاء
الامم المتحده كل المؤسسات الدوليه كل
المؤسسات الدوليه صندوق النقد ومنظمه
التجاره العيه اللي انشا ده في امريكا
مؤتمر سان فرانسيسكو الخيط الصعود
التاريخي مع الصعود التاريخي لامريكا بدات
تورر
مصالحها كقوه عالميه كقوه
عالميه مصالح اقتصاديه مصالح سياسيه مصالح
استراتيجيه واصبحت القوه انا استمعت حضرتك
مره
الحلقه مع صديق عمري دكتور جوود عبد
الخالق وافتكر كده استخدم تعبير ساخر
بقوللك امريكا
يشهق الاخرين العرق الاخرين وما زالت وما
زالت باشكال مختلفه يعني
طب نعم بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه بدات
امريكا تتوسع كقوه عالميه في اطار الحرب
البارده وفي اطار التنافس مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي من خلال احلف عسكريه حلف
الاطلنتي 49 من خلال معاهدات اقتصاديه
وسيطره على اوروبا مشروع
مارشال ثم سلسله من الاحلاف العسكريه
المحليه زي حلف بغداد هي ما انضمت للحلف
بريطانيا اللي كانت في الحلف انما هي دخلت
لجنه متابعه الانشطه الهدامه ودعمت الح
حزب حلف بغداد ا التحالف مع تركيا دعم
باكستان في في المرحله الاولى طبعا دورها
في انشاء اسرائيل دور حيوي وبدات بقى نشات
ولن اتردد في هذا الامبراطوريه الامريكيه
بعد الحرب العالميه الانيه بس مش
امبراطوريه بالمعنى القديم احتلال
الاراضي يجوز من احتلال الاراضي من ناحيه
انشاء قواعد عسكريه لا توجد في العالم لها
قوات منتشره في اكثر من 100 دوله في
العالم شكل قواعد عسكريه بعض بيقدر عدد
القواعد العسكريه ليها في كل دول العالم
بحوالي 800 اه على اساس مثلا بلد زي
المانيا فيها عده قواعد عده قواعد طبعا ف
هذه
الامبراطوريه يعني هي بتحدث في اطار نظام
دولي هي اسسته هي
اسسته اللي هو الا المتحده وصندوق النقد
الدولي بنك الدولي الى ومؤسسات اخرى انهار
ح السوفيتي اطلق لها اصبحت هي اكثر تجبرا
بقى اكثر تجبرا وبالتالي يعني يعني
التاريخ لغايه 45 مرحله من 48 49 ل 90 91
مرحله مرحله من 2 بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي نقول
لغايه 1112 2011 2012 مرحله ومن بعدها
مرحله انيه بقى اللي هو الصعود الروسي
والصيني طيب هل استاذن حضرتك في ايجاز
تقول لي الان الولايات المتحده سبب العنف
اللي بتمارس او السبب ال بسيط جدا ومختصر
اتفضل هي هذه المرحله النهارده اتكلم عن
النهارده اه بتشعر ان في حد بيشد السجاده
من تحت رجليها اللي هي الصين ومعها روسيا
وبتحس حضرتك ان الكرسي اللي هي قاعده عليه
اللي هو كرسي قده العالم بيهتز بيهتز
بتشعر ان في حاجه اسمها الصين قاعده تقترب
منها دون المبالغه في قوه الصين عشان ما
زالت الاقتصاد الامريكي يعني سابق حجم
الاقتصاد الصيني بكثير بكثير والصين عندها
مشاكل طبعا انما ما زالت بتنمو وتمثل
تهديدا للمكان هنا يعني اللي يدل هي في
اخر وثيقه للامن القومي الامريكي النص ان
الصين بحكم ما تمتلكه من عناصر القوه
الشامله تمثل التهديد
الرئيسي للامن القومي الامريكي حط جنب
الصين دي التهديد ده
ان حرب حصلت في اوكرانيا بغض نظر عن
اسبابها وامريكا مارست كل انواع العقوبات
الاقتصاديه
لهزيمه روسيا وما قدرتش بس هذا لا دي
معلومه مهمه استاذنك حضك تقول ان امريكا
حاولت بكل وسائلها هزيمه روسيا في
اوكرانيا ولم تفلح وبتدل بدا على على ان
هي شعره ان مكينتها بتهتز بتهتز اقتصاديا
من خلال كذا وبتهته
عسكريا من خلال عدم قدرتها على فرض
الهزيمه على روسيا خير دلوقتي
حوالي سنتين حوالي سنتين اقل من سنتين
بعده شهور وروسيا لا تبدو طبعا عندها
متاعب ما فيش كلام انما عزيمتها في القتال
مستمره دورها الدولي مستمر سياستها
الخارجيه نشطه اسطا تحشد حولها عدد كبير
من الدول ليست دوله معزوله او ابدا ابدا
او منعزله فامريكا
حط حط ل على ده حط على ده وطبعا حرب
اوكرانيا حرب اوكرانيا قدمت لامريكا فرصه
العمر هو اعاده الهيمنه الامريكيه على
اوروبا على اوربا على اوروبا انت فاكر من
عده سنوات كان يقال كان ده تعبير حتى
ترامب ان حلف الاطلنطي في غرفه الانعاش اه
وانه والدول دي ماحدش من الدول دي بيدفع
نصيبه او
بدفعو نصيبهم في ميزانيات الدفاع كلهم
معتمدين على امريكا وحاجات زي كده هي حرب
اوكرانيا اعاده
فرض اليد الغليظه الامريكيه على انما شوف
كل فعل له رد فعل هتلاقي في بقى بدايات
تمرد جوه الاتحاد
الاوروبي الخلاصه امريكا تدافع عن مكانتها
في العالم على مكانتها القياديه في العالم
سؤال الاخير معالي الدكتور قبل اختم
الحلقه دي اللي هي الحقيقه حلقه ممتعه ان
احنا نسمع فيها على حضرتك
العالم العربي عاش وطبعا في سنوات
استقلاله الاولى اجواء الحرب البارده
الاولى ما بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
السوفيتي بدايه من 47 الى سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي في اول التسعينات وشفنا ايه اللي
حصل في العالم العربي وانقسامه بين الشرق
والغرب وفي دول شهد مقاسي واشعال حروب على
ارضه الان احنا
بنشهركو
فقني في هذا التصنيف ما بين الولايات
المتحده من ناحيه وما بين الصين وروسيا
ودول اخرى من ناحيه اخرى حضرتك بتتوقع انه
الدول العربيه تعيش ايضا اجواء الحرب
العالميه الحرب البارده الاولى ولا الوضع
يكون مختلف انا بس ح ايه يعني توصيف الوضع
الرا انه حرب بارده يعني يحتاج بس الى
مراجعه لان في حرب سخنه ما بين روسيا
والعالم الع الغربي فيعني هي الحرب
البريده الحرب البريده كان احد عناصرها
عدم اللجوء الى القوه انك بتحاول تحل
باسلب اخرى ف يعني العلاقه بين امريكا
وروسيا لا حرب حرب عسكريه ساخنه ساخنه
الصين
وامريكا حرب برده ت فيها اساليب مختلفه
الى اخره زيما يعني المفروض المفروض
الرئيسين يلتقوا في نهايه السنه دي في شهر
اكتوبر كان وزير الصين وزير الارج الصين
راح امريكا يعني خليط من التوترات
السياسيه وايضا المصالح الم الشرك اه انا
عايز اقف مش هرجع الماضي بقى الحالي ارجع
ليه سنه 22
2022 السعوديه شهدت مؤتمرين خطيرين جدا
مؤتمرات قمه واحد افتكر في يولي او اغسطس
اللقاء مع بايدن مع بايدن كان حاضر حوالي
10 رؤساء دول
عربيه او اكتر واللي بايض
كان اذا جاز التب كان بيحي وقال لقد تركت
امريكا المنطقه وحدث في فراغ حاولت دول
اخرى ان تملاه ولن يسمح بذلك ده صحيح بكلم
على الصين
وروسيا الكلام ده حدث بعد نشوب الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه بعده
شهور على ديسمبر جا الرئيس الصيني الصيني
انا بعتبر الاتنين دول بيعبروا عن
المزاج العربي الحكومي والشعبي بص حضرتك
على تصويت الدول
العربيه حتى الدول الحليفه او القريبه من
الولايات المتحده في الامم المتحده انا
هسيب القر الاول القرار الاولان اللي هو
كان موضوع على اوكرانيا على الاوكرانيا ا
اغلبيه الدول العربيه
رفضت تاييد المشروع الغربي
بت تجميد عضويه روسيا في مجلس حقوق
الانسان التابع للامم المتحده الدول
العربيه لم تشارك في
اجراءات الع العقوبات الاقتصاديه على
روسيا ماقدرش اقول المزاج العربي في مجمله
معادي لروسيا
ابدا مش عايز يقول العكس انما يعني مختلط
الامر المؤكد ان طبعا بتمارس ضغوط على
البلاد العربيه لا شبهه في
هذا وفي امثله ل كده امريكا بنبه على
الدول على كل العالم لا تتعاملوا مع شركه
هواوي الصينيه الج الجيل الخامس وخدوا
بالكم الشركه دي لما بتعمل لكم اي تتجسس
عليكم بتتجسس عليكم يجوز في دوله او
دولتين
عربيتين يعني
اتبعوا الموقف الامريكي في دول عربيه ما
عملتش رئيس الوزراء المصري دكتور مصطفى
مدبولي كان في الصين في شهر
اكتوبر ممثلا لرئيس الجمهوريه في مؤتمر
الحزام والطريق طبعا الرئيس السيسي ما
كانش ممكن
يسيب الاحداث غزه ويسافر يعني فلما حد
يشوف كده عمل ايه الدكتور مصطفى المدولي
احد المقابلات
مع رئيس مجلس اداره شركه هوو ماعرفش عمل
ايه او وقع ايه و ما وقعش ايه ك قبل وكع
معاه معناه انه ادرار ظهره للمطلب
الامريكي شان دول اخرى كثيره بالضبط
بالضبط بالضبط في نفس الوقت حجم
التجاره
السعوديه الاماراتيه واغلب الدول العربيه
مع الصين هي الشريك الاول ايه هي الشرك
التجار الاول شريك الت للخليج كله الصين
طبعا الله ما تقوليش بقى ده بس تتجر
المصالح
الاقتصاديه بتؤدي الى ارتباطات ومصالح
سياسيه انا عايز اقول رد مباشر عليك لن
يكون الامر سهلا انه نقول هناخد ده وناخد
ده في ضغوط من الولايات المتحده على الدول
العربيه ومن الاطراف الاخرى ومن الاطراف
الاخرى كل منها يحاول ان يجذب اكبر عدد من
الدول العربيه اعتقد شعوري ان اغل اغلب
الدول العربيه لن ترى مصلحه لها في
الانحياز الكامل لاحد الطرفين عاوز اختم
بسؤال اخير معالي الدكتور انا عارف ان
السؤال عام وربما يكون من الافضل لما اكلم
عالم سياسه ان انا اطرح عليه سؤال
سبيسيفيك ومحدد ولكن اذا سالت حضرتك توقعك
في السنوات القليله المقبله الخمس سنوات
10 سنوات اللي هتشت عل فيهم المواجهات ما
بين الولايات المتحده وحلفاء من ناحيه
والصين وروسيا والدول اللي هي بتقف في
معسكرهم زي ايران وغيرها يعني وكوريا
الشماليه هل تعتقد ان السنوات المقبله في
الغالب سوف تكون سنوات اضطراب وفوضه وحروب
على هذه المنطقه من العالم اللي هو العالم
العربي بشرقه وغربه ام لا توقعك يعني
توقعي
يعني يعني طبعا عنصر رئيسي
فيها كيف
ستنتهي الحرب الدائره الان في فلسطين
الطريقه اللي هتحل بها و تنتهي بها هتبقى
حاسمه لان الوضع في فلسطين هو العنصر
الرئيسي اكبر قنبله موجوده في
المنطقه الحاج
الانيه المفاعل النووي ماشي وفي توترات
صعودا وهبوطا لكن مافيش مواجهه يوميه
عسكريه تص المفاعل النوي الايراني
البرنامج النوي
الايران توترات وكذا الى اخره انا بعتقد
الطريقه التي سوف تسوى بها او ينتهي بها
القتال الدائر في فلسطين الان هيبقى عنصر
حاسم في شكل المنطقه اعتقد وانا موافق لما
نتنياهو قال ان شكل الشرق الاوسط هيختلف ا
هيختلف شكل الشرق الاوسط في الخمس سنوات
القادمه لن يكون
قبله في تقارب بين دول كانت اعداء
ا يعني من يومين اسرائيل سحبت البعثه
الدبلوماسيه بتاعتها من تركيا اه قلا
ايران اللي ما كانش لها تم اتصالين
تليفونين مع السعوديه ومصر يعني لا لا مع
سامح شكري مع سامح
شكري الوزير الوزير الايراني تحدث مع مصر
مرتين تليفونيا يعني ان في
وشائج بدات تظهر وتبان في ملامح لتح
تحالفات او تقاربت مختلفه عما كان موجودا
موجودا نعم وحضرتك بتقول انهض ما اعتقدش
اسرائيل هتنسى بسهوله المواقف المصريه اه
ولا مصر هتنسى المواقف ال هذه الحرب ذكرت
الجميع بمن العدو وم صديق ا يعني الحديث
ان اسرائيل اوقفت ضخ الغاز الى مصر ا طبعا
اه و كان الضغط على مصر ودي الازمه في
الكهرباء ده احد اسبابها الرئيسيه انقطاع
الكهرباء في مصر مبوط مزبوط انت اللي انت
عملته في
فلسطين هيطلع جيل جديد الراي العا العربي
صوره اسرائيل اختلفت تماما يعني الشباب
اللي عمره 30 سنه او 40 سنه ونشوا
من يعني ان في علاقات دبلوماسيه وفي كذا
الدنيا اختلفت حجم هذا العمر في الدنيا
اختلفت الشباب الفلسطيني والتصاعد والرغبه
في التطبيع السابقه اكيد ه تنزوي الى حد
كبير العجله دي كلها او القطار ده كله
يعني يا اما اوقف يا اما دمر ا في هذه
الفتره لذلك انا بقول اشكل هتنتهي بهذه
العمليه هيبقى هو دوت العنصر الحاسم او
الرئيسي في هذا الامر طب وانا ممكن اسال
حضرتك ولا من المبكر ايه ايه السيناريوهات
المتوقعه ان ينتهي بها الموقف في غزه صعب
يقول لك لا انا لست من الغفله ان ايب على
هذا السؤال اه
من المبكر
نعم على كل الاحوال انا بشكر حضرتك انا
اللي بشكرك والله ز معال الدكتور وان شاء
الله خلال الايام تنجلي الصوره بشكل اوضح
ونستضيف حضرتك وتقول لنا ان شاء الله كيف
انتهى الامر او كيف يمكن ان ينتهي الامر
وما يمكن ان يترتب عليه من اثار على منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والعالم جزيل الشكر معال
الدكتور شكرا جزيلا متشكر قوي قوي ربنا
يخلي حضرتك وشكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم
مع الدكتور علي الدين هلال في حلقات اخرى
باذن الله والى اللقاء